Leading up the, the last quiz, we already had a lot of information about our
situation. And we'd also picked out what really mattered to us. In terms of how
we need to go about finding the cost to make one wiper set. In the last quiz, we
added one more piece of information to this list. And I'm going to write that
out a little bit more formally now. We decided that we would represent this
quantity right here, the cost to make one wiper set, by a variable. I'm going to
pick the letter c for that variable. C is going to equal the cost to make 1
wiper set. To move one step closer to having a formal mathematical equation to
describe our situation, I'd like to help us get some other numbers in our
equation. Looking at this given information up here, can you tell me two numbers
that equal, respectively, the cost to make 92 wiper sets, and the number of
wiper sets that are made. This is going to help us with substitution, in the
next step of the process.